[Music]
probably my parents they are they left
like Civil War entry I got to give me a
better life then he had one kid because
they knew they're going to provide for
one kid so for me that's the kindest
thing you can ever do my brother brought
me to the Pirates and I was 16 and he
promised like when I was like 5 and he
bring me and then he did so that was
really nice
I remember my dad's band was uh it
wasn't working and it was temporary it
would turn on and other times it would
it and so I decided to turn off the fan
in the middle of the street while the
light was red and so I tried to turn it
back on and they wouldn't turn on and I
don't know where I see a guy just
running behind me helping you push that
and I was so grateful it was such a
beautiful amazing experience and it's
something that just I remember honestly
I want to say but me some we don't um
giving me my son having a son that's
pretty much the kind of thing
my mother's loved by the kindest thing
well these two gentlemen here are good
friends of mine and when I had cancer
they were tremendously supportive my
brothers from a different mother
[Music]
so when I was like six we were really
poor we didn't have a Christmas tree my
mom told us like
that someone's gonna deliver it you know
some like that and so the me being young
I thought the oil delivery guy was the
guys bring the tree so like did you
bring the tree so like six four hours
later he came back with the office tree
and a buncha get some stuff and that was
just the most awesome thing ever
my wife every day all I can say every
day she does everything that I need I
really had to ask her that's the kindest
thing I could never probably get I did
my wife when I was little I was about
six and I was put in foster care and
sometimes you don't know who's gonna
come get you because you're a little kid
and I have someone who got me she's my
foster mom but she's been my foster mom
since I was six and I'm 21 so that's the
kind of thing someone's ever done for me
given me a business yeah I think a see a
business that was already established
and it was worth like $45,000 and they
had all the faith in me in the world to
take it over and I took it over um she
was my boss and now she's a friend she's
my mentor and I love her and yeah she's
an angel in my life for sure someone
introduced me to God because they've
completely changed my mind
you know from nothingness to something
from darkness to light totally changed
my perspective of life what I do now in
my life so probably that's nothing good
it beat that I think
when I came here in the United States my
boss they believed me and he gave me you
know he was my sponsor to get my
citizenship my my papers my green card
and
I'm really thankful for him you know
because he's been 18 years already and
I'm blessed to be here I love to be in
America everybody here is very nice are
very kindly my friends let my daughter
win this trip I think the kindest thing
anyone's ever done is when my mom we
found out she had cancer and I was in
college
this guy that I barely knew but we we
were in a group together offered to let
me have his car to take her to chemo
therapy whenever we needed it and I was
really kind of I think the kind of thing
that people in general
that I don't have the best attitude
because of what has happened to me in
the past but even then people still
around me managed to show love for me to
me that's the kind of thing ever because
sometimes I feel like I don't deserve it
a friend of mine there's a really good
musician kind of like took me under his
wing and has been teaching me for the
past year just how to get better and has
brought me into his band and has just
done a lot to help me grow as a musician
and I just feel like that's really kind
of him to do and not necessary at all my
dad got me my car I had like a 93 Volvo
station wagon I was like in shreds and
then we got me a new car I was like in
tears because I could finally go to one
place 20 and it became like one piece
kind of thing is my lady friends kind of
thing that she she straightened me out
[Music]
somebody taught me how to fly it started
out with him being my instructor for
flying what's called a paramotor and you
know now he's more than just my
instructor he's my friend something you
would normally pay somebody for he takes
me out to mountains and I learned how to
take to the skies just with the power of
the wind hitting that mountain I'm a big
fan of small acts of random kindness
opening doors and holding a door open so
I think just someone holding a door open
for me is it's just a act of random act
of random kindness to me that's a big
deal
this man just took me for vacation I
loved it I was on a flight from LA to
Phoenix and this woman came or this
woman sitting next to me she was praying
the entire time because there was a lot
of turbulence on the plane and she ended
up giving me a Bible and she said that I
got told her to give me the Bible she
was she just said that something told
her that kept us safe during the storm
that we conclude
and I just thought it was really really
special I think I still have the Bible
somewhere
then I was alone here and I was kind of
like lost Ben first I got here my uncle
actually helped me to figure it out my
what am I supposed to do with my life
and I think that was so nice of him to
like you know put aside all of his life
these issues that he had on that time to
help me one of my homies like help me
get a really good job
that was pretty legit just gave me a
reference to like a his dad's company
actually and like I still work there as
dope well I mean this guy introducing
himself yesterday because we both like
went to a hostel together and we didn't
have any friends when we showed up so
that was that was pretty kind when I was
going through at a hard time and I was
at the grocery store couldn't pay for my
groceries I was humiliated had a cart
full of stuff told my friend I went home
like it was tearful she left it came
back with tons of groceries to give me
she knew that I was in a bad place and
couldn't be with myself so it touched me
and it's something I'll always remember
because it meant a lot to me in memory
of win Scott we miss her and think of
her often
we love you Lynne one of my tires blew
on and this guy came out and he helped
me prepare to blast
my piano teacher mrs. Lyman gave us
kennel lessons for just two dollars
she did that
so so many of us learned how to play
piano
it's ladies standing reciting married me
the kindest thing anybody ever did
[Music]
[Music]